welcome back so let's do a potential
energy with problem with a compressed
spring so let's let's let's make this an
interesting problem so let's say I have
a loop-de-loop a loop-de-loop made out
of ice and I made out of ice so that we
don't have friction so let me draw my
loop-de-loop loop-d-loop there's the
loop there's the D loop alright and
let's say this loop de loop has a radius
of 1 meter let's say this is this right
here is 1 meter and so of course the
loop de loop is 2 meters I 2 meters high
and let's say I have a a spring here
it's a compressed spring let's say this
is the wall this is my spring it's
compress so it's all tight like that and
let's say it's spring constant K is I
don't know 10 and attached to that
compressed spring so I have a block of
ice can I need ice on ice so I have no
friction this is my block of ice shining
and let's say the block of ice is I
don't know 4 kilograms 4 kilograms and
we also know that we are on earth and
that's that's important because this
problem might have been different if we
were on another planet and my question
to you is how much do we have to
compress the spring so you know let's
say that the springs natural state was
was here right if there if we didn't
push on it and now it's here so what is
this distance how much do I have to
compress this spring in order for when I
let go of the spring the block goes with
enough speed and enough energy that it's
able to complete the loop-d-loop
and and and reach safely to the to the
other end so how do we do this problem
well well in order to any loop-de-loop
problem the hard part is is completing
the heart the high point of the
loopty-loop right the hard part is
making sure you have enough velocity at
this point so that you don't fall down
your velocity has to off
set the downward acceleration in which
case and here is going to be the
centripetal acceleration right so that's
one thing to think about and you might
say wow this is complicated Atmos bring
here it's going to accelerate the block
and then the block is going to get here
then it's going to decelerate decelerate
this is probably where it's going to be
at its slowest then it's going to
accelerate back here it's a super
complicated problem and in physics
whenever you have the super complicated
problem it's probably because you are
approaching it in a super complicated
way but there might be a simple way to
do it and that's using energy potential
and kinetic energy and what we learned
in when we learn about potential and
kinetic energy is that the total energy
in the system doesn't change it just
gets converted from one form to another
so it goes from potential energy to
kinetic energy or you know or to heat
and we assume that there's no heat
because there's no friction so let's do
this problem so what we want to know is
how much do I have to compress the
spring so what I'm essentially saying is
how much potential energy do I have to
start off with when with this compressed
spring in order to make it up here so
let's what's the potential energy let's
say I compress the spring X meters so I
compress the spring X meters and in the
last video how much potential energy
would I then have well I we learned that
the potential energy of a compressed
British spring and I'll call this the
initial potential energy the initial
potential energy with an eye is equal to
1/2 K x squared and we know what K is I
told you that the spring constant for
this spring is 10 so my initial
potential energy is going to be 1/2
times 10 times x squared so 10 x squared
so what are all of the energy components
here well obviously at this point the
block is going to have to be moving in
order to not fall down so it's going to
have some velocity V is going tangential
to the loop-de-loop and it also is going
to have some potential energy still and
where is that potential energy coming
from what's going to come it because
it's it's up in the air it's it's above
the surface of the loop-de-loop so it's
going to have some gravitational
potential energy right so
at this point we're going to have some
kinetic energy we'll call that well just
call that kinetic energy final because
this is why we care about although maybe
you know here might be the kinetic
energy final but I'll just define this
as kinetic energy final and then let's
plus the potential energy final and that
of course has to add up to 10 x squared
and this of course now this was kind of
called the spring potential energy and
now this is gravitational potential
energy so what's the energy at this
point well what's what's the kinetic
energy kinetic energy final kinetic
energy final is going to have to be 1/2
times the mass times the velocity
squared right and then what's the
potential energy at this point its
gravitational potential energy so it's
the mass times gravity times this height
right so potential and so I'll write
that here potential energy final is
going to be mass times gravity times the
height which also stands for Mass
General Hospital anyway why you can tell
my wife's a doctor so I know my brain
just I don't know anyway so let's figure
out the kinetic energy at this point so
what does the velocity have to be well
we have to figure out what the
centripetal acceleration is well and
then and then given that we can figure
out the velocity because we know that
the centripetal acceleration and I'll
change colors for variety centripetal
acceleration it has to be the velocity
squared over the radius right or we
could say and and what what is this
interpreted acceleration at this point
was just the acceleration of gravity 9.8
meters per second squared
so 9.8 meters per second squared is
equal to V squared over R and what's the
radius of this of this loop-de-loop well
it's 1 so V squared over R is just going
to be equal to V squared so if V squared
equals 9.8 we can take the square root
or we could just substitute the 9.8
straight into this equation right so the
kinetic energy final kinetic energy
final is going to be equal to 1/2 times
the mass
times four times V squared times 9.8 and
that equals that equals let's just say
let's just use G for 9.8 because I think
that might keep it interesting so this
is just G right so it's 2 times G so the
kinetic energy final is equal to 2 G and
you know G is normally kilogram meters
per second squared but now where its
energy right so it's going to be in
joules but it's 2 G all right and what
is the potential energy at this point
well it's the mass which is 4 times G
times the height which is 2 so it's
equal to 8 G right so what's the total
energy at this point the kinetic energy
is 2 G the potential energy is 8 G so
the total energy at this point is 10 G
10 G total energy 10 G so the total
energy at this point is 10 G and we
didn't lose any energy to friction and
heat and all of that so then the total
energy at this point has also got to
equal 10 G and at this point we have no
kinetic energy because this block hasn't
started moving yet so all of the energy
is of potential energy so this also has
to equal 10 G and this G I keep saying
is just 9.8 I just wanted to do that
just so you see that it's a multiple of
9 point a just for you to think about so
what do we have here all these numbers
worked out well so let's divide both
sides by 10 you get x squared is equal
to G which is 9.8 so the X is going to
be equal to the square root of G which
is going to be equal to what let's see
if I take 9.8 and take the square root
of it it's like 3 point 1 3 so X is 3
point 1 3 so in order so we just did a
fairly what see me what seemed to be
difficult problem but it wasn't so bad
we just said the whole day with the
energy in the beginning has to be the
energy at any point in this assuming
that none of the energy is lost to heat
and so we just figured out that if we
can press compress the spring with the
spring constant of 10 if we compress it
3.3 me
three point one three meters we will
have created enough potential energy and
in this case the potential energy is 10
times 9.8 so roughly 98 joules 98 joules
of potential energy to carry this object
all the way with enough velocity at the
top of the loop-de-loop to complete it
and then come back down safely and so if
we want to think about it what's the
kinetic energy at this point well we
figured out it was 2 times G so it's
like nineteen point six joules or is
that you know 9.19 point six right and
then at this point it is it is 98 joules
all right did I do that right
well anyway well I'm running out of time
so I hope I did do the last part right
but I'll see in the next video